bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur Public Sénat voici le programme de
votre après-midi l'avenir des colonies
de vacances en débat au Sénat elle
serait en déclin alors que le nombre
d'enfants qui ne partent toujours pas en
vacances reste inchangée pour en parler
on retrouvera Tam tra nuit en direct de
l'hémicycle du Sénat dans un instant et
puis il y a 18h15 prof par 3 à
l'émission politique de la rédaction de
Public Sénat qui reçoit aujourd'hui
Michel Barnier le français fait figure
de candidats du compromis pour prendre
la tête de la Commission européenne et
puis on se retrouve à 19h pour 24 heures
Sénat le journal on parlera service
minimum à la veille d'une grève
nationale de la SNCF avec nouveaux
invités ce soir Mireille Church c'est
natrice communiste et l'UMP marque
Lamini mais l'autre actualité
aujourd'hui au Sénat c'est l'avenue de
Manuel Valls devant le groupe EPS
objectifs pour le Premier ministre
convaincre Christophe du soutien des
sénateurs socialistes à une semaine de
la présentation en conseil des ministres
du projet de loi sur la réforme
territoriale alors le message est-il
bien passé voyez ses réaction au micro
de Mounir souci
de ce que vont proposer les
parlementaires et en particulier les
sénateurs nous qui avons cette charge de
l'organisation des territoires c'est
notre ADN la chambre haute le problème
c'est que pendant les dix années où nous
avons été dans l'opposition
nous n'avons pas travaillé
nous n'avons pas préparé cette grande
réforme et par conséquent nous devons
aujourd'hui en même temps
réfléchir sur ce qu'il convient de faire
et le faire et c'est là que les
difficultés apparaissent Michel Barnier
commissaire européen chargé du marché
intérieur et des services a été
auditionné par les sénateurs de la
commission des finances pour lui il a
crise a montré la faiblesse de la
monnaie unique on l'écoute
l'intérêt si je puis dire de cette crise
c'est qu'elle a révélé
les toutes les faiblesses européennes en
même temps et notamment celle que
Jacques Delore
clairement identifiés au début de l'Euro
qui est on ne peut pas avoir une zone
monétaire unique une union monétaire et
une désunion économique budgétaire et
fiscale
et puis si je puis me permettre au delà
de ces faiblesses collectives le
fonctionnement la gouvernance de la zone
euro l'absence de supervision européenne
efficace trop grande dérégulation
financière les faiblesses propres à
chaque pays de la zone euro notamment et
si cette crise a révélé aussi quelque
chose d'important ne l'oublions jamais
c'est que dans cette zone euro et en
Europe en général le problème de l'un
devient très vite le problème de tous
Michel Barnier qui sera donc l'invité de
prof par 3 est-il le candidat du
compromis pour la Commission européenne
pour la présidence de la Commission et
les mondes réponse avec Michel
grossiorer à 18h15 je vous le disais en
titre le Sénat des bas en séance
publique de l'avenir des colonies de
vacances c'est à l'initiative du groupe
communiste on va tout de suite retrouver
tom-tranuy en direct de les mines cycles
alors bonjour Thomas quel est l'enjeu de
ce débat et bien écoutez les jolies
colonies de vacances célébrées par
Pierre Perret Pierre Perret qui a
d'ailleurs été cité à plusieurs reprises
dans l'hémicycle cet après-midi c'est
joli colonies de vacances non plus la
cote en depuis le début des années 90 on
est passé de 24 millions de nuités
annuelles en colonie de vacances à 14
millions un chiffre donc divisé par 2
les séjours sont par ailleurs de plus en
plus courts et les colonies peinent à
satisfaire leur objectif de départ c'est
à dire favoriser l'autonomie de l'enfant
aussi permettre plus de mixer sociale
faire en sorte que des enfants de
différents milieux sociaux puissent
partir en vacances ensemble qu'est-ce
qui explique Tom et bien le déclin de
ces colonies de vacances écoutez ces
colonies sont de plus en plus chers
elles sont indexées sur le coup de la
vie et les conditions de sécurité et
d'encadrement sont de plus en plus
contraignantes cela est normal mais
c'est un coup lourd à supporter en
période de crise pour l'État pour les
collectivités locales ou encore pour les
comités d'entreprise autre problème et
bien les colonies sont de plus en plus
divisées en deux catégories d'une part
il y a les colonies de luxe pour les
enfants favoriser d'autre part il y a
les colonies pour les familles les plus
modestes et donc à ce titre et bien
l'objectif de mixité sociale n'est plus
du tout satisfait enfin les colonies
sont menacées par certaines mesures
envisagées ou actuelles et cela a été
dénoncé tout à l'heure par le groupe
communiste dans les muscles en parlant
d'abord du gel des seuils sociaux dans
les entreprises ou bien encore de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires
qui fait qu'il y a des besoins de
financement supérieur pour les centres
de loisirs et donc la victime
collatérale serait les colonies de
vacances bref le droit aux vacances pour
tous est très loin d'être satisfait
rappelons qu'aujourd'hui 34 % des
enfants de ouvriers ne partent pas en
vacances et on monte à 50 % si on parle
des familles les plus modestes
merci beaucoup Tam pour vos explications
alors sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour suivre cette séance et
son se retrouve tout de suite après je
vous rappelle le débat quel avenir pour
les colonies de vacances à la demande du
groupe CRC la parole est tout d'abord à
l'orateur du groupe qui m'a demandé ce
débat en l'occurrence madame Isabelle
Pasquet
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
communément appelé et colonie de
vacances les séjours de vacances sont
incontestablement marqués notre mémoire
collective des souvenirs qui nous
renvoient notre propre expérience à
celle de nos enfants Pierre Perret en
apporte un certain témoignage certes
très personnels la chanson mais les
colosse n'est pas simplement yukaïdi
yukaïda c'est surtout une démarche qui a
permis aux jeunes de nos villes de nos
départements de nos entreprises de
partir en vacances et d'avoir accès à
une forme d'éducation qui revendique son
caractère populaire
en effet si les premières colonies de
vacances en France comme ailleurs en
Europe ont été le fait de patronage tant
religieux que laïque elles avaient déjà
outre une vocation sanitaire évidente
une dimension sociale indéniable elle
s'adresse alors essentiellement aux
enfants d'ouvriers qui doivent faire
face à des conditions de vie précaires
résultant notamment d'une
urbanisation rapide des ordonnées dans
la finalité résidait plus dans la
satisfaction des besoins industriels
nouveaux que dans l'amélioration de vie
des ouvriers et de leur famille
la Ligue de l'enseignement créée en 1866
et fervent défenseur de l'école laïque à
largement contribué à l'organisation de
séjour à destination des enfants et à
vocation sanitaire sociale mais aussi
éducative la période de
l'entre-deux-guerres marquée par
l'émergence de revendications nouvelles
et par la volonté d'acteurs associatifs
mutualiste syndicaux et politique de
construire une société plus juste et
plus solidaire participera à
l'amplification de ce mouvement on peut
parler même d'un basculement car il ne
s'agit plus seulement de mettre de
permettre aux enfants d'ouvriers
d'accéder à des loisirs et un
environnement sain mais de favoriser le
développement personnel des jeunes pour
cela on avait besoin d'un encadrement
formé c'est ainsi que sont créés les
premiers centres d'entraînement puis le
réseau de Semea centre d'entraînement
aux méthodes d'éducation active charger
eux de former les animateurs notamment
puisque les colonies ne sont pas justes
un lieu où le jeune passe du temps
puisque la colonie est un lieu
d'éducation et de construction alors il
faut comme à l'école des règles de
fonctionnement et le personnel encadrant
doit être formé l'idée majeure étant que
les jeunes s'approprient des savoirs
dans un contexte qui n'est ni familial
ni scolaire dans le but de construire le
citoyen de demain cet objectif explique
pourquoi la mixité sociale et
particulièrement importante
initié par des structures non
gouvernementales les colonies de
vacances et le mouvement d'éducation
populaire auquel elle se rattache
recevront dès 1936 la pluie du Front
populaire avec la création du premier
secrétariat aux loisirs au sport dirigé
par Léo Lagrange les municipalités
essentiellement de gauche s'engageront
activement pour assurer les besoins de
leur population faisant des colonies un
élément de leur politique en direction
des jeunes basées sur des valeurs de
solidarité et de partage
dans ce cadre le mouvement d'éducation
populaire et précurseur pour ce qui est
de l'enseignement en faveur de la
protection de l'environnement
le monde salarié n'est pas en reste et
progressivement les comités d'entreprise
dotées de budget pour les activités
sociales vont au lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale participer eux aussi au
développement des colonies de vacances
je profite du coup de cette intervention
pour dire combien la mesure envisagée
par le ministre du Travail de gelée
pendant trois ans les seuils sociaux
seraient dramatiques vous n'êtes pas
sans ignorer mes chers collègues que les
comédiens d'entreprise participent au
financement des activités de loisirs des
salariés et de leurs enfants cette
mesure si elle devait être appliquée se
traduirait un câblement par une paire de
pouvoir d'achat des salariés
municipalités associations et comités
d'entreprise ayant une volonté commune
de permettre au plus grand nombre
d'accéder à des séjours en dehors du
cadre familial en dehors des
convergences financières à mi-femmemain
entre vacances et éducation pour tous
les colonies se distinguent de l'école
par le fait que les enseignements ne
sont pas scolaires et les méthodes non
académiques on y apprend par
l'expérience par le jeu ou le sport et
par la rencontre avec les autres comme
le précise le dernier ouvrage publié par
le Conseil scientifique des Francas
intitulé l'éducation populaire en jeu
démocratique les colonies de vacances
favorisent l'émancipation de tous par
tous et pour tous un citoyen acteur qui
peuvent dès lors contribuer par leur
puissance sociale à la transformation de
notre société républicaine vers plus
d'équité et d'humanité
la meilleure illustration de la volonté
des acteurs de l'époque et la formidable
et ambitieuse expériences de la colonie
des maths en Charente-Maritime initié
par la commune d'Ivry appelée aussi la
République des enfants ces derniers
étaient appelés à appliquer durant leur
séjour les principes démocratiques en
élisant parmi eux leur représentants
chargés de travailler et avec les
encadrants à la résolution de petits
conflits et des questions d'organisation
on voit comment à travers un projet
éducatif ambitieux se conjugue un
partage complémentaire entre savoir
établi et savoir démocratique avec
l'objectif de la participation active
des jeunes à la construction d'une
société respectueuse de chacun et de son
environnement
compte tenu de cet objectif ambitieux
vous comprendrez mes chers collègues que
le groupe communiste républicains et
citoyen et souhaité inscrire à l'ordre
du jour du Sénat la question de l'avenir
des colonies de vacances d'une part
l'ambition des colonies de vacances nous
semblent plus que jamais d'actualité
d'autre part se pose de plus en plus la
question de la pérennisation des
colonies confronté à une logique
marchande qui s'opposent au tourisme
social en général dans un contexte
marqué par les réductions des aides
financières allouées par les pouvoirs
publics
si les facteurs sont variés le constat
est clair malgré l'apport singulier pour
les jeunes le nombre de colons et chaque
année en est diminution
on s'en sert en 1913 100 000 enfants en
colonies un million en 1955 mais le
constat formulé par un centre des
observateurs et dans la réduction du
nombre de jeunes vacanciers depuis la
fin des années 90 qui partent en colonie
le rapport de lAssemblée nationale sur
l'accessibilité des jeunes au séjour
collectifs et de loisirs soulignent de
réalité
un les jeunes sont moins nombreux à
partir et singulièrement dans les
classes populaires et deux des séjours
sont plus courts force de constater que
ce déclin est d'abord d'ordre économique
lorsqu'on interroge les familles la
première raison donnée pour ne pas
envoyer leur enfant en colonie de
vacances et majoritairement celle du cou
du séjour se déclin coïncide avec un
coïncide en réalité avec la période de
crise économique qui pèse sur les
familles mais aussi sur les
municipalités aujourd'hui les acteurs du
tourisme social municipalités
associative association comité
d'entreprise qui veillaient à ce que les
centres de vacances soient des lieux de
rencontre des différentes réalités
sociales sans concurrencés par une offre
marchande plus coûteuse plus spécialisée
et élitiste comme le précise le rallye
directrice d'études à l'École des hautes
études en sciences sociales auteur de
l'histoire des colonies de vacances de
188 de nos jours se déclin coïncide je
cite avec l'arrivée d'une offre
marchande sur ce secteur qui va conclure
concurrencer la colonie classique avec
son projet éducatif construit autour de
la mixité sociale de la communauté
enfantine et le vivre ensemble pour ces
organismes la rentabilité passe avant le
projet éducatif le prix d'une semaine de
vacances en colonie coûte entre 400 et
600 euros par enfant avec un coût moyen
à la journée de 63 euros selon
Jean-Louis de Roussin président de la
Caisse nationale des allocations
familiales un séjour de 12 jours dans un
centre de vacances agréés par les CAF
revient en moyenne à 574 euros une somme
importante
trop lourde pour des familles modestes
pour qui malheureusement les
préoccupations quotidiennes se loger se
nourrir se vêtir l'emporte sur le droit
aux vacances et ce d'autant plus mais
j'y reviendrai ultérieurement que la
partie passion de la Caisse
d'allocations familiales au séjour en
colonie un être humain diminué au cours
des années
pour autant ce n'est pas la seule cause
les colonies associatives communales ou
gérée par des comités d'entreprises
connaissent également un accroissement
important des prix de telle sorte que la
vocation sociale est de plus en plus
difficile à exercer
l'autre constat que nous pouvons faire
et le raccourcissement de la durée des
séjours au summum de la fréquentation
des centres de vacances en 1995 toute
période confondue le ministère comptait
28 millions de nuitées depuis ce nombre
d'acc de diminuer sur un rythme beaucoup
plus rapide que la diminution du nombre
de départ en 2011-2012 le ministère ne
compte plus que 14 millions de journées
enfants en centre de vacances
c'est à dire à peu près la moitié cet
effondrement de la fréquentation
dissimulée par une moindre baisse du
nombre de départ évalué à 15% sur la
même période la durée moyenne de ces
jours de plus d'une semaine incessée de
se réduire passant de 17 jours en 1994 à
moins de 10 jours aujourd'hui les durées
les plus pratiquées étant désormais 5 à
8 jours les séjours de deux semaines
complètent représentent encore 20% de
l'offre en revanche les séjours de 3 et
4 semaines qui étaient la norme pendant
l'âge d'or des colonies sont en voie de
disparition
reconnaître ces deux réalités c'est de
fait s'engager dans la voie de la
réflexion pour que le succès populaire
des colonies d'hier soit retrouvé demain
dans l'intérêt des enfants et de notre
société mais les réponses sont parfois
plus complexes qu'elles ne semblent être
de premier abord bien entendu personne
ne peut ni que le coup de l'organisation
des colonies de vacances à augmenter
dans des proportions importantes c'est
une conséquence de l'augmentation du
coût de l'hébergement de ces des prix de
l'alimentation ou encore de celui de
l'énergie c'est également une
conséquence de la croissance
l'accroissement du nombre et de la
qualité des équipements cadrante
dans le cadre de séjour avec hébergement
une solution contestée notamment par des
associations d'employeurs dans la mesure
où elle participerait à augmenter le
prix du séjour d'où la proposition que
l'on retrouve dans le rapport remis à
l'Assemblée nationale de remplacer le
statut de salarié par celui de bénévoles
indemnisé selon la reportanteur de
l'Assemblée nationale sont volontariat
s'adresserait à toute personne de moins
17 ans qui veut s'engager dans une
mission d'intérêt général à finalité
éducative auprès d'une personne morale à
but non lucratif agréé pour l'accueillir
selon les termes posés par la plateforme
du volontariat à l'aide de l'animation
tout au long de la vie le volontaire
peut s'engager pour une durée annuelle
limitée et fractionnelle fractionnable
cette proposition tentante a priori
parce qu'elle aurait pour effet de
réduire le coût des colonies de vacances
pourraient nous apparaître au groupe CR
c'est une solution peut-être trop simple
voire même simpliste au regard des
enjeux le rétablissement d'un droit
effectif aux vacances pour tous et dans
la mixité sociale et des difficultés
réelles qui excèdent de loin la question
de la rémunération des règles d'un
encadrement je voudrais avant d'aller
plus loin dans mon raisonnement rappeler
quelques évidences
ce qui a fait le succès des colonies de
vacances c'était que les enfants
allaient gagner en maturité en autonomie
que l'expérience de la vie en
collectivité autour d'adultes référents
formés aux besoins spécifiques des
jeunes enfants il adolescents disposant
de savoir pédagogique permettait aux
jeunes de se développer dans le respect
des règles communes mais les parents
veulent également avoir la certitude
que les conditions de réalisation des
activités s'effectue en toute sécurité
que la vie ou la santé de leur enfant
n'est pas en danger lorsqu'il participe
à une colonie de vacances c'est
préoccupations mes chers collègues sont
légitimes vous en conviendrez c'est la
raison pour laquelle je ne pense pas
qu'aux prétexte d'une réduction de coûts
il faudrait réduire nos exigences en
termes de qualité des prestations
hôtelières des activités proposées ou de
l'encadrement le débat sur les colonies
de vacances de se limite pas à un
problème de coûte mais plus largement
nous avons à nous interroger sur le
modèle social dans son ensemble que nous
voulons pour nos enfants
ceci étant le rapport de la mission
commune d'information semble faire de la
question du statut des animateurs une
question cruciale mais paradoxalement il
souligne également et cela me paraît
extrême le nom important que le repli
des classes populaires et moyennes sur
les séjours un centre de loisirs ou sur
les vacances familiales serait moins dû
selon les organisateurs de séjour à la
hausse des prix car la réorientation des
aides sociales au départ en colonie le
rapport précisant et c'est à Messieurs
un élément central que la démission et
la diminution de ces aides directes et
indirectes et augmenter le coût résiduel
du séjour pour des familles qui n'ont
plus les moyens d'envoyer leurs enfants
en colonie sans une aide substantielle
on ne saurait dire mieux au titre de
cette réorientation des subventions
publiques comment ne pas souligner la
démission notable des aides accordées
par la CAF et notamment la suppression
des bons vacances
selon une étude de l'Observatoire des
vacances aux plein air des enfants et
des jeunes parus dans son bulletin de
décembre 2005 donc 10 ans après le début
de la crise des colonies de vacances il
y aurait une relation directe et
déterminante entre la disparition des
bons vacances auparavant distribués par
les caisses d'allocations familiales et
la baisse de fréquentation des colonies
cette réorientation de la participation
financière de la CNF est en réalité la
conséquence d'une circulaire
d'orientation des dépenses d'aide
sociale publiées par la CNAV donc la
caisse constatant la stagnation de ces
recettes et la faible efficacité sociale
des bons vacances choisit de revoir
l'usage des ressources affectées du
Fonds national d'action sociale FNAS
comme celui défend les ciel à la
discrétion des conseils d'administration
des caisses
ces réorientation dans les priorités de
la CNAF apparaissent dès le début des
années 80 et s'accentue au fur et à
mesure que les mécanismes d'exonération
des cotisations sociales croissent je
l'ai déjà dit il y a plusieurs reprises
et notamment dans ma qualité de
rapporteur d'abranche famille
la branche famille à travers sa caisse
et la principale victime de cette
politique alors que nous apprêtons à
examiner le pdfss rectificatif qui
intérrinera sans doute le pacte conclu
entre le gouvernement et le Medef avec
la clé plusieurs milliards
d'exonérations de cotisations patronales
supplémentaire je veux redire que toute
suppression de ressources a des
conséquences sur les familles et
singulièrement les familles modestes la
politique menée en continu depuis plus
de 20 ans de réduction des cotisations
sociales à la charge des employeurs à un
prix celui de la réduction du champ de
la solidarité nationale celui de la
perte d'ambition d'un système formidable
et émancipateur né à l'issue de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale celui du
sacrifice d'un droit pourtant
fondamental des vacances pour tous et
entre tous
et c'est sans compter l'impact de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires c'est un
substance ce que rappelle le haut le
Haut Conseil de la famille
dans son avis adopter le 5 février 2013
il attire l'attention sur la croissance
des besoins de financement des accueils
de loisirs et des autres activités
périscolaires qui découlera de la mise
en place des nouveaux rythmes scolaires
à l'opposé des coupes envisageables à la
suite de l'application du pacte de
responsabilité le Haut Conseil invite le
gouvernement à renforcer le financement
de la CNAV à hauteur d'un milliard
d'euros tout simplement pour faire face
aux besoins issus de cette réforme
nécessairement de nouveaux choix devront
être opérés Monsieur Philippe Didier
Courbin adjoint la directrice générale
chef de service des politiques sociales
et médico-social explique nous
souhaitons que les caisses soutiennent
ces départs mais il y aura sans doute de
leur part une prédilection en faveur des
centres de loisirs en raison de
l'aménagement du temps scolaire tout
cela mes chers collègues me confort dans
la nazie n'a l'analyse qui est celle de
mon groupe il est urgent de rebâtir un
nouveau pacte social ambitieux et
solidaire capable de renforcer la
sécurité sociale plutôt que d'assister à
son délitement progressif c'est ce
constat qui nous conduira prochainement
certainement lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative à nous opposer à
la réduction des cotisations à la
réduction des cotisations de patronales
et a proposé un financement alternatif
solidaire faisant enfin de la
satisfaction des besoins de notre
population la ligne conductrice des
politiques que nous avons amenés
autre source d'inquiétude pour notre
groupe le mauvais sort réservé aux
communes j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
rappeler que dans le passé avec le Front
populaire est plus encore au lendemain
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale les
communes avaient largement investi le
chant des loisirs et n'avait pas hésité
à acquérir des terrains déstructures
pour y construire leur propre colonies
de vacances certaines d'entre elles je
pense par exemple à la mairie de
Gennevilliers n'avait pas hésité à
instaurer une modulation des prix en
fonction de la situation financière des
familles
introduisant pour la première fois un
quotient familial dans la fixation des
tarifs des colonies décisions qu'il
faut-il le rappeler avait été attaqué
par le préfet au motif que le maire
avait pris une décision discriminatoire
contraire aux principes régissant les
services publics recours cassés par la
juridiction administrative ouvrant ainsi
le chemin une pratique aujourd'hui
répandue dans les communes qui
concernent les colonies
et forcé de constater qu'elles sont de
moins en moins nombreuses et là encore
il s'agit clairement d'une question de
choix politique et de la détermination
des élus locaux assurés pour leur
population un droit effectivement aux
vacances pour tous et des vacances qui
ne sont pas uniquement et lieu de
détente mais un lieu de construction
culturel un lieu d'épanouissement un
lieu qui apprend à vivre ensemble mais à
l'avenir la question du maintien de ces
lieux se posera nécessairement y compris
pour les plus déterminés des élus locaux
le gel des dotations le recul de la
solidarité nationale n'est pas sans
conséquence sur les communes les plus
modestes qui de même plus encore
qu'aujourd'hui seront contraintes
d'opérer des choix et réaliser des
coupes y compris dans des postes qu'ils
estiment essentiels les ai sans compter
l'impact sur l'activité économique dans
les communes à vocation touristiques
vous le voyez mes chers collègues
l'avenir des colonies de vacances
c'était étroitement liés à la question
de l'avenir de notre pacte social pour
notre part nous sommes défavorables aux
mesures préconisées par certains qui
tiennent qui tendraient à réduire plus
encore les droits et les rémunérations
des moniteurs ou en rabattre sur les
conditions d'encadrement des jeunes
colons je pense notamment à la mesure
proposée par la mission commune
d'information de l'Assemblée nationale
qui préconisait ni plus ni moins que de
substituer au sanctuaire statut actuel
des moniteurs un statut de bénévole
à ce stade de mon intervention je
voulais mais je vois que je n'ai plus
guère de temps je voulais évoquer
l'accident qui est survenu à l'étranger
qui a trouvé la mort de deux adolescents
cet accident extrêmement grave doit nous
interroger sur les conditions d'accueil
et d'organisation des séjours notamment
à l'étranger
et d'ailleurs j'aurais aimé avoir votre
avis madame la ministre sur ce sujet
nous sommes cependant convaincus qu'il y
a urgence de prendre une mesure forte de
nature assurer la pérennité financière
des colonies le rapport de l'Assemblée
nationale préconise de l'instauration
d'une taxe sur l'hôtellerie de luxe dont
le produit pour être affecté un Fond
national cette mesure nous semble être
de nature apporter un bol d'air
salutaire pour les colonies de vacances
et pour les familles aussi madame la
ministre je voudrais conclure mon
intervention vous interrogeants
également sur la position du
Gouvernement sur cette proposition je
vous remercie merci ma chère collègues
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
Monsieur François Fortin pour le groupe
RDS
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le temps des jolies
colonies de vacances
chères à Pierre Perret et qui ont
illuminé notre jeunesse semble
élastominer
les chiffres fournis par l'Observatoire
des vacances et le loisirs enfants et
des jeunes la très pour l'économie de
vacances
ne cesse diminuer de produire de deux
avec un dernier pic de fréquentation qui
remonte en 1995
la fragmentation des séjours est apparue
dans des années 90 à compliquer le
comptage mais le nombre nuitées est un
indicateur très valable et très parlant
et on a recensé
28 millions de nuitées en 95
pour 14 millions en 2011-2012
séduire les fonds
étaient les principaux soutiens aux
organisations organisateur aux
associations organisatrices de séjour
pardon en tant que Lulu local il suffit
également de se référer aux réalités de
terrain pour s'en convaincre de
nombreuses communes qui avaient acquis
des centres de vacances en bord de mer
ou à la montagne les ont revendus ou
reconvertis à ce titre le site la belle
demeure de France propose des annonces
pour des petits châteaux dans lesquels
il est clairement indiqué colonie de
vacances à vendre
mon département
touchée par ce phénomène
et concerner en particulier par
l'extension de certains nombres
de centres de vacances du fait de
réparation de plus en plus coûteuse qui
ne peuvent être effectuées autant dire
que l'âge d'or des colonies de vacances
et derrière nous en particulier celui de
la première où on le voyait des trains
remplis d'enfants partir en collo près
de
13300 lieues de séjour en 1951
sans doute tous les enfants
ayant grandi n'ont pas gardé la
nostalgie des colos mais globalement
elles ont rempli un rôle social qu'il
convient de saluer de poursuivre en
effet elles étaient à leur origine
guidées par des considérations
hygiénistes voire confessionnelle les
colonies de vacances ont été ensuite
massivement récupéré par les
associations laïques qui ont intégré des
enjeux éducatifs les ondes rendus
beaucoup plus attrayants pour toutes les
classes sociales et aussi pour les
autorités publiques qui ont ainsi
longtemps soutenu en priorité des
contenus de vacances mais plusieurs
facteurs
ont porté un coup d'arrêt à cette
évolution
d'abord l'adaptation aux nouvelles
périodicités de vacances avec le
développement des Minikeums de moins
d'une semaine dans les centres de
loisirs de la commune ou dans le camp de
scouts qui n'ont pas la ce qu'on pensait
la l'extension des colonies de vacances
à ce propos nos collègues députés en ni
je ne Var et Michel Ménard ils ont
recensés dans leur rapport d'information
déposé dans les dernières
c'est 21 propositions pour les colos du
21e siècle nous pouvons bien entendu que
partager ce constat mais il faut dire
qu'il y a des choses qui sont mesurables
donc qui ne le sont pas et l'attrait de
moins en moins grand pour les colonies
de vacances
des enfants des milieux défavorisés tout
simplement pour une raison c'est que
quand on est inconnu de vacances il faut
se lever un certain horaire alors que
quand on est en famille il arrive
quelquefois que à ce niveau il y a une
très grande laxisme
le coût est une des raisons souvent
avancées par les familles en effet pour
s'adapter aux nouvelles exigences de la
société les organisateurs de colonies
ont dû proposer des formules souvent
plus coûteuses
l'enfant du 21e siècle n'est plus celui
du 20e que l'on débute au moins de l'ami
du milieu du 20e que l'on faisait
marcher dans la campagne au seul rythme
d'un kilomètre à pied ça use les
souliers aujourd'hui avec ce genre de
considération vous n'allez pas attirer
le chaland
c'est évident le développement des
séjours thématiques souvent orientées
sur un sport où l'apprentissage d'une
langue étrangère a répondu à une
nouvelle demande mais malheureusement
elle s'adresse au milieu sociaux aisé
que ce soit sur le plan matériel ou sur
le plan culturel
et là encore les milieux les plus
modestes en sont sinon exclus du moins
présente pas un après considérable pour
ce genre d'activité
puis il faut quand même parler argent
puisque cela est déjà été dit il faut
compter 400 à 600 euros par semaine pour
un coût moyen de 3 euros par jour on est
loin des 10 ou 15 euros par jour pour
les séjours de scoutisme et même pour
les 35 euros d'une journée en centre
loisirs sans herbergement type centre
aéré
il semblerait que cette hausse
s'explique par la réorientation des
aides sociales d'un côté
et puis en prenant l'acte de la
désaffection des enfants pour les
colonies dans leur format traditionnels
les Caisses d'allocations ont favorisé
les aides au séjour de proximité et le
soutien aux accueils de loisirs et aux
familles on peut difficilement le
reprocher car elles ont inscrit leur
politique dans une tendance qui certes à
peut-être accentuée le phénomène des
affections des pour les colonies de
vacances se met à laisser
progressivement
entrer dans une logique commerciale
on peut observer le même phénomène
s'agissant des comités d'entreprise qui
privilégie davantage les aides
financières directes famille par le
biais des chèques vacances plutôt que le
maintien des grands centres ce propos
Silas SNCF a conservé
45 centres et propose encore des départs
en vacances pour 15000 enfants La Poste
qu'entre elle cédait tout son patrimoine
et n'a plus de colonies de vacances
j'ajouterai que la multiplication
des normes d'encadrement imposées par
l'État ajouté aux difficultés des
associations alors que contrairement à
une idée reçue les colonies de vacances
sont moins accidentogènes que le milieu
familial ou amical
au final un schématisant un peu il
résiste tout cela que nous avons un
système à deux vitesses d'un côté un
système associatif et caritatif qui
propose des garderies d'été très
demandées en milieu périurbain ou des
journées à la mer pour les enfants des
quartiers
et d'autres une offre commerciale de
colonie thématique réservée aux enfants
les plus favorisés dans ce contexte les
enfants des classes moyennes sont
souvent écartés
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure le fait que
l'attrait était moindre du fait d'une
discipline de moins en moins acceptée à
l'approche des vacances d'été se
débarque au reporter nos sensibiliser le
gouvernement allant nécessité de donner
une nouvelle ambition à la politique
d'aide au départ en vacances c'est en
tout cas une préoccupation pour nous
radicaux de gauche les inégalités
persistantes l'accès en vacances
constitue une brèche
du pacte social républicain parce que
les vacances contribuent à la cohésion
des liens familiaux et sociaux elles
doivent devenir un droit fondamental
j'évoquerai l'action de Sylvia Pinel
lorsqu'elle avait en charge le secteur
du tourisme
qui se proposait de lutter contre la
fracture touristique et comme il y a
madame la ministre une permanence l'état
dans ce pays
je souhaite ardemment avec mes collègues
que vous repreniez à votre compte de ces
idées le départ en vacances des enfants
est une grande cause qui doit nous
rassembler tout ce quel que soit nos
sensibilités c'est un problème qui est
d'importance mais n'oublions jamais que
il faut essayer de trouver les clés
permettant de redonner aux enfants le
goût des colonies de vacances et ça ça
n'est pas forcément avec des moyens
financiers que nous y parviendrons il
faut d'autres leviers
si je les connaissais je voulais dirai
je me contente simplement d'observer que
lorsque les travaux sont réalisés de
modernisation
ils intéressent une catégorie sociale
c'est exact c'est ce qui sont devenus
adultes et qui ont fréquenté les
colonies de vacances et qui trouve que
c'est moins cher bien entendu que les
parties autres hôtelières
traditionnelles et qu'on y trouve
beaucoup de plaisir à venir qui en
montagne qui a la mer qui a la campagne
mais c'est pas avec cela que l'on
relancera les colonies de vacances
madame la ministre il nous faut faire
preuve collectivement d'imagination mais
vous avez pour vous un argument que je
n'ai plus c'est celui de la jeunesse
merci la parole est à Madame Corinne
bouchou pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je tiens tout
d'abord à remercier le groupe CRC pour
avoir porté ce sujet aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle l'accès aux enfants des
vacances et adolescents dans une forme
collective demeure un sujet d'actualité
et un ange central pour notre jeunesse
et notre société et à ce propos je me
demande d'ailleurs si dans les divers
problèmes qui ont été signalés fort
justement par notre premier
intervenantes il n'y a pas aussi le
problème du nom colonie de vacances
colonie je suis pas sûr que ça fasse
rêver dans l'imaginaire aujourd'hui
vacances oui mais colonies ça fait plus
rêver
alors selon l'Observatoire des vacances
et des loisirs des enfants et des jeunes
un quart des 5 19 ans sont aujourd'hui
exclus du départ en vacances soit près
de 3 millions d'enfants et d'adolescents
c'est cela dont nous parlons aujourd'hui
un Richard rapport déjà cité du député
Michel Ménard en juillet 2013 dresse un
état des lieux très alarmants de la
fréquentation des colonies de vacances
en baisse depuis 1995 quel que soit les
indicateurs pris les journées la durée
ou le nombre d'enfants en colonie nous
partageons donc ce constat à savoir que
alors que les séjours collectifs
diminuent les inégalités augmentent très
fortement comment renforcer l'accès des
mineurs aux loisirs et aux vacances
comment garantir un droit à des vacances
pour tous sous une forme organisée selon
nous l'expérience du départ est
fondatrice partir ailleurs partir en
dehors de son milieu familial d'origine
est une expérience qui ouvre à
l'altérité de même qu'à l'apprentissage
de la vie collective à travers ses
règles ses contraintes les contraire etc
on trouve là des similitudes avec les
classes de découverte dont le nombre
dans le système de l'éducation nationale
a malheureusement aussi diminué depuis
1999 mais les colonies et les mini camps
ont lieu eux pendant les vacances les
enfants les adultes ainsi rassemblés ont
plus de temps pour vivre à un autre
rythme autour de projets co-construits
qui permettent d'échanger y compris sur
la construction d'un futur proche c'est
enfin pour les enfants faire
l'expérience d'un autre lieu qui était
son horizon de tous les jours découvrir
d'autres espaces découvrir la mer
apprendre à connaître la montagne
parfois des pays étrangers mais aussi
découvrir les espaces ruraux leur faune
leurs flore des enfants qui découvrent
d'autres lieux d'autres cultures qui
font l'expérience de la vie en
collectivité et participe à de tels
projets collectifs pourront mieux se
projeter mieux s'imaginer un parcours de
vie et auront plus de facilité à entrer
dans d'une dans une dynamique de projet
qui est si souvent valorisée de de nos
jours y compris à l'école la baisse de
la durée des vacances et du nombre de
séjour frappent plus fortement les
familles aux revenus les plus modestes
et s'étend aussi aujourd'hui au
classement moyenne voire parfois aux
classes supérieures lorsqu'en cas de
chômage les parents renoncent à ce type
de séjour pour leurs enfants les
difficultés économiques sont plus
fortement ressenties par les familles de
milieux populaires et modestes c'est une
évidence nous en avons déjà parlé ici
mais il est possible que le changement
de système mis en place pour les
moniteurs depuis 2011 et quelque peu
fragiliser le système puisqu'il y a de
fait induit une hausse des coûts des
colonies qui peut-être sont aussi
devenues plus chers pour un certain
nombre de familles hormis les autres
explications donner lors de la première
intervention pour nous écologistes de
levier serait à prioriser la première
serait de refondre peut-être le paysage
de l'animation et dans un deuxième temps
de réfléchir à l'accompagnement et
l'aide au départ concernant la refonte
nécessaire du paysage de l'animation
nous pensons que cette réflexion devra
aller de pair avec l'évolution des
activités périscolaires la
professionnalisation des auxiliaires
pour les enfants mais aussi la question
des jeunes en situation de handicap sans
oublier la question des esprits c'est là
que nous posons la question du statut
d'animation volontaire qui pourrait
trouver toute sa place un parcours
limité dans le temps qui permettrait de
découvrir une logique d'engagement dans
des projets
un autre aspect mérite d'être souligné
les animateurs aujourd'hui ne veulent
pas forcément de plus de temps de repos
mais de rémunir mes veulent des
rémunérations descentes c'est peut-être
aussi cela la crise de vocation dans les
colonies de vacances les directeurs de
séjour eux veulent des animateurs
impliqués qui restent plus longtemps ils
ne veulent pas passer leur temps à faire
et défaire des plannings ce qu'ils sont
d'ailleurs devenus
de plus les associations en tout cas
celles qui nous ont contactées qui sont
d'accord pour se passage à involontaria
de l'animation serait d'accord pour que
dans un premier temps il y a une phase
transitoire ou plusieurs systèmes
d'animation existeraient il est selon
nous grand temps de repenser ce statut
deuxième point l'accompagnement et
l'aide au départ l'accompagnement au
départ doit se faire localement en
co-construction de tous les acteurs
cette démarche nous semble extrêmement
importante
il faudrait organiser plus de
coopération de proximité le rôle des
communes est important les cas font un
rôle stratégique cela a été dit tout à
l'heure et donc on peut constater que le
modèle économique et social des CAF a
été très fortement fragilisée parce
qu'il a été dit dans la première
intervention
nous pensons finalement que
malheureusement Leia léthane ayant plus
prétendant ne plus avoir les moyens de
financer les séjours en colonie de
vacances il faut aussi se tourner vers
d'autres acteurs qu'il faut associer à
ces séjours collectifs il y a le rôle
des fondations même si nous avons des
réserves quant au fondations il y a le
rôle stratégique et cela a été dit des
comités d'entreprise donc là si on va
trop loin dans les histoires d'effets de
seuil on va encore avoir moins de comité
d'entreprise opérationnelles et encore
moins de structures qui pourront aider
les enfants à partir
pour finir nous considérons qu'il est
important de remettre à l'ordre du jour
le rôle de ces vacances collectives que
l'on appelait autrefois les colonies de
vacances et nous partageons une des
propositions numéro 11 du rapport de
Michel Ménard qui parlait de développer
des réseaux territoriaux de départ des
jeunes en séjour collectif permettant le
partage du coup des séjours par le
jumelage des collectivités dans le cadre
des projets éducatifs territoriaux ou
bien en ravivant les jumelages européens
et internationaux dans ce domaine nous
trouvons cette initiative intéressante
même si comme toujours ces initiatives à
l'international profitent plus aux
jeunes de milieux privilégiés qu'aux
jeunes de milieu modestes en fait la
vraie question de fond est celle des
inégalités qui ont massivement explosé
dans notre société et dont les colonies
de vacances ne sont qu'un reflets le nom
des parts relaque une partie de la
jeunesse celle qui a pourtant le plus
besoin d'un espoir et d'un horizon merci
d'avoir posé cette question aujourd'hui
merci la parole est à Monsieur Alain
Dufau pour le groupe UMP
sur le Président Madame le ministre mes
chers collègues
c'est vrai que les colonies de vacances
ont connu par le passé un grand succès
créé à la fin du 19e siècle pour les
raisons de santé publique afin d'envoyer
des enfants au grand-père elles ont pris
au XXème siècle sans éducatif qu'il soit
d'ordre laïque ou confessionnel
à partir de la Libération l'État c'est
impliqué directement dans leur
développement transféra en leur tutelle
à l'éducation nationale et leur
consacrant des moyens importants
et dans les années 60 près de 1 million
400 000 enfants fréquentés les séjours
collectifs soit 11% des 5 à 19 ans et
nous sommes nombreux ça a été dit ici
avoir fréquenté à cette époque la colo
moi le premier par la suite à partir des
années 70 l'éducation nationale se
désengagea de la fonctionnement en
faveur du ministère des Sports
la fonction éducative des colonies étant
passé de mode la société ayant évolué et
les familles partant de plus en plus en
vacances le nombre de séjour d'été
diminua considérablement
mais une seconde phase de croissance
succéda à la première
reposant cette fois sur des courts
séjours pendant l'année
soumise à un nouvel impératif de
rentabilité les colonies ont dû
s'adapter aux demandes des parents qui
ne recherchent plus seulement pour leurs
enfants
l'apprentissage de la vie en
collectivité mais aussi
un accès à des activités culturelles de
sport ou de loisirs
et les offres sur catalogue se
développèrent
leur économie postéran le taux de départ
des 119 ans atteignant 14% en 1995 comme
disait tout à l'heure François Fortassin
alors pourquoi ce taux n'est-il plus que
de 7 et demi pour cent en 2011 que
s'est-il passé
et quels sont les conséquences de cette
désaffect désaffection
bien la mission qui a été créée par la
commission des affaires culturelles de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est emparé du
sujet et a rendu effectivement ses
conclusions en juillet 2013 ce qui a
motivé l'inscription de ce débat à notre
ordre du jour par nos collègues du
groupe communiste
le rapport identifie plusieurs causes à
cette baisse des fréquentations des
colonies de vacances tout d'abord
d'ordre financier avec l'augmentation
des prix des séjours en colonie de
vacances la suppression des subventions
de l'État et de la sécurité sociale et
aussi le retrait des comités
d'entreprise dernier soutien des
colonies qui abandonne souvent l'achat
de séjour collectifs au profit de chaque
vacances
par ailleurs si vous aussi que les
parents sont devenus réticents envoyer
leur enfant en colonie doutant
quelquefois les conditions d'accueil
craignant pour leur sécurité et on a
observé qui privilégie bien souvent des
centres de loisirs des communes qui
accueillent habituellement leurs enfants
et proposent des mini camps de vacances
enfin
les contrats administratives et
réglementaires sont devenus de plus en
plus importantes notamment en matière de
sécurité ou pour appliquer de nouvelles
normes sur l'accessibilité
et concernant l'animation les contrats
d'engagement éducatifs ont été mis en
cause par la jurisprudence européenne et
du Conseil d'État en ce qui ne
garantissait ni un statut ni un temps de
repos satisfaisant pour le personnel
encadrant
ça n'est suivi bien évidemment une
insécurité juridique et des surcoûts
pour les organismes qui se sont mis aux
normes résultats aujourd'hui le pays des
colonies de vacances de plus en plus
segmenté
d'un côté une population en grande
difficulté qui fait l'objet d'aide
ciblées pour des séjours onéreux
les familles aisées s'adressant à des
opérateurs privés proposant des
prestations beaucoup plus attrayantes et
les classes moyennes privées d'aide et
de ressources suffisantes ne trouvent
finalement pas leur place dans ces
dispositifs
les colonies c'est vrai sont donc
manifestement en perte de vitesse et
nous le partageons tous cette situation
est parfaitement regrettable tout
d'abord parce qu'elles sont un espace de
socialisation ça a été dit et
d'expérimentation important pour les
jeunes et bien sûr un outil de mixité
sociale et je vois pas mal de
similitudes avec la suppression de
l'ancien service militaire
ensuite parce qu'elle participe aussi au
développement du tourisme et à
l'économie de nos territoires notamment
en ruraux et en montagne
enfin parce qu'aujourd'hui près de 3
millions d'enfants et de jeunes ne
partent pas en vacances et ce phénomène
est grave
je pense donc l'État doit retrouver
effectivement relatif d'incitateur des
parents colonie
et assurer le maintien des centres
vacances surtout notre territoire
national
cependant les solutions préconisées par
le rapport de l'Assemblée nationale à ce
sujet repose quelques fois sur des
financements
difficil facilement mobilisable qu'il
s'agisse d'une taxe supplémentaire sur
les vacances familiales ou de la
récupération des aides sociales
distribuées par la CAF
l'obligation pour les TPE de proposer
des chèques-vacances me semble également
difficilement envisageable surtout en
cette période de crise
autre proposition la taxation de
l'hôtellerie de luxe ça a été dit outre
qu'elle me semble particulièrement
démagogique et stigmatisante viendrait
incontestablement fragiliser un secteur
économique dans les activités
participent au développement du tourisme
en France alors
que proposez-vous à ce sujet Madame le
Ministre
c'est pas facile
sans doute faut-il travailler dans une
nouvelle direction
innover pour rendre de nouveaux ces
séjours beaucoup plus attractifs
le succès est même le regain des camps
de scoutisme qu'il soit confessionnels
ou laïque doit nous faire réfléchir aux
valeurs et à la forme de loisirs que les
familles privilégiées aujourd'hui
autre point si je suis réticent
concernant certaines propositions du
rapport je m'associe volontiers à la
demande de repenser le statut des
animateurs c'est un des points
certainement les plus cruciaux
l'épisode juridique concernant les repos
journaliers a bien montré la nécessité
d'une réforme
le respect de la législation
de nombreux centres préfèrent
aujourd'hui être en situation
irrégulière ou même annuler des séjours
les mouvements d'éducation populaire
demandent donc la création d'un statut
de volontaire de l'animation
rompant avec la réglementation du
travail salarié
ce qui je le crois clarifierait la
situation est constituée par ailleurs
une certaine reconnaissance de leur
expérience que pensez-vous de cette
proposition
que globalement quelle mesure
envisagez-vous pour assurer
l'accès de tous les enfants des vacances
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs collective ou
familiale
les colonies de vacances c'est vrai sont
un modèle qui a déjà beaucoup évolué et
comment comptez-vous les accompagner
dans le franchissement de la crise
qu'elles connaissent et qu'elle traverse
actuellement
car au-delà d'une certaine nostalgie
pour les jolies colonies de vacances je
pense que le sujet mérite que l'on s'y
intéresse
il représente effectivement un enjeu
important pour notre jeunesse et
l'économie de nos collectivités je vous
remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Joël guerriot pour le groupe
udi
UC
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues dans le contexte
économique social et politique que nous
connaissons un débat sur l'économie de
vacances peut surprendre et tu
l'opportun de s'interroger à la veille
des vacances d'été alors que nos
concitoyens attendent des réponses aux
questions les plus urgentes liées à leur
quotidien
autrement dit la création première
n'est-elle pas où et comment partir en
vacances mais plutôt comment boucler des
fins de mois de plus à l'heure où l'on
nous reproche un excès de loi et de
réglementation avec une simplification
se fait attendre le législateur doit-il
intervenir aussi sur le fonctionnement
des colonies de vacances
je pense que oui
voyez comment les choses peuvent être
surprenantes je pense que oui tant les
colonies de vacances sont d'un intérêt
national elles sont un prologement de
l'éducation et une possibilité de
nivellement des différences sociales
pour les enfants dont les parents ne
partent pas en congé un quart et ça a
été répété par mes collègues des enfants
ne partent pas en vacances c'est le cas
pour 34 % des enfants d'ouvriers et 50%
pour les familles les plus modestes les
collines de vacances présentent un
intérêt collectif double d'une part dans
le prolongement de l'école elle
constitue un apprentissage privilégié de
la vie en collectivité les séjours
collectifs de mineurs apportent beaucoup
aux enfants individuellement une
aération une ouverture sur des activités
nouvelles et bien sûr la sociabilité
d'autre part et c'est fondamental elle
devrait constituer un temps de partage
en mixité sociale
mais au 21ème siècle les colonies de
vacances ont bien changé elles ne sont
plus forcément ce lieu et ce moment de
brassage socio-culturel au contraire il
semble que deux formes distinctes de
colonies est évoluées les unes plus
lucratives et thématiques et les autres
de plus en plus réservés un public
social une autre réalité mobilise notre
action celle de l'érosion de la
fréquentation des centres de vacances le
taux de départ des 5-19 ans en séjour
collectif de vacances dépasse 105000 etc
7%. ils étaient encore 14% en 1995 les
comités d'entreprises se sont
progressivement désintéressés de cette
formule alors que les offres devenaient
plus spécialisées sur des thèmes assez
variés et de plus en plus cher il faut
ajouter à cela la suppression des
subventions qui compensaient ces écarts
pour les familles modestes
la mixité sociale n'est plus le point
des colonies de vacances pour répondre
aux attentes des clients elles se sont
spécialisées et en se spécialisant elles
ont segmenté l'offre et donc la
fréquentation
l'essor des séjours thématiques
provoquent des tarifs élevés liés à la
surenchère des offres par exemple les
séjours linguistiques sont hors de
porter des enfants
issus d'un milieu modeste à l'inverse
les familles aisées se détournent des
colonies de vacances qui ne proposent
pas un niveau d'activité répondant à
leurs attentes la conséquence et
l'instauration d'un entre soi social des
séjours au détriment des enfants des
classes moyennes qui sont pourtant les
garants de cette mixité sociale autre
problématique de taille sur laquelle
repose le débat d'aujourd'hui le statut
de l'animateur la remise en cause du
modèle économique des colonies de
vacances participent à une hausse des
tarifs puisque le coût d'un animateur
salarié n'a rien à voir avec les
pratiques de rémunération traditionnelle
le statut de l'animateur s'est
professionnaliser entraînant des
obligations contractuelles
et générant obligatoirement une hausse
des coûts pour les organisateurs et des
prix de séjour pour les parents
entraînant une augmentation également et
une baisse de fréquentation
face à cette situation trois
propositions nous semble propriétaire
prioritaire à travers ce rapport la
première a pour objectif de réinsérer la
mixité sociale ce sont les cinq
premières propositions du rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale qui ont été
présentés par le député socialiste
Michel Ménard qui lui aussi est de
Nantes je tiens à rappeler que les
colonies de vacances n'ont pas vocation
à accueillir uniquement des publics
segmentés pourtant selon la puissance
d'un comité d'entreprise ou les moyens
d'une commune le niveau des activités et
la qualité des lieux d'accueil crée une
hiérarchie sociale il me paraît donc
primorial de faciliter l'accès des
séjours collectifs au plus grand nombre
et notamment en direction des classes
moyennes dans le contexte que nous
connaissons ou les marges de manoeuvre
financière restent faibles faibles il
est de notre devoir de ne pas en faire
porter les conséquences aux plus jeunes
générations
monsieur le député Ménard propose de
créer un Front national d'aide au départ
en vacances collectif financé par un
nouvel taxe sur l'hôtellerie de luxe la
question qui se posera c'est ce fond
serviront-ils réellement la cause des
séjours des jeunes des classes moyennes
espérons-le autre piste plus les
opérationnelles au soutien des départs
en vacances celle d'une adaptation des
chèques-vacances il est encore trop peu
connu que des chèques-vacances sont
maintenant accessibles à tous les
salariés y compris ceux des entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés et donc sans
comité d'entreprise une visibilité plus
large de cette offre permettrait
d'optimiser le financement des séjours
des enfants de salariés négocier avec
l'Association nationale des
chèques-vacances la création d'un chèque
spécifique au séjour collectif pour les
mineurs me semble être une piste
intéressante
une campagne nationale de promotion des
colonies de vacances couplées à
l'instauration de chaque vacance dédié
permettrait un nouvel élan à la mixité
sociale et la fréquentation de ces
séjours collectifs le rapport propose
également de solliciter la SNCF à
présenter une offre commerciale
favorable au transport de groupes de
mineurs plus adapté au contrat des
organisateurs de séjour en tant plus de
cheminots étant ayant été à la fois
colons dans les à la SNCF ou encore
animateurs je trouve que SNCF devrait
effectivement apporter sa pierre à ce
projet ensuite le rapport lit huit
propositions pourraient organiser les
trop nombreuses acteurs du secteur
autour d'un réseau plus dynamique
mutualisant les moyens et bénéficiant de
la belle c'est une immense chantier de
concertation d'associations et d'entente
qui pourra coordonner en fait ces
travaux sans créer des contraintes
nouvelles dans un secteur où tous les
acteurs se connaissent déjà bien mais
non pas jusqu'à ce jour manifester la
moindre volonté de se regrouper
mais surtout comparant les
infrastructures les associations les
comités d'entreprises et les
municipalités peinent à entretenir et à
garder aux normes leur patrimoine
immobilier destinés à accueillir les
jeunes ces colos de bord de mer ou de la
montagne sont vieillissantes et
deviennent au fil du temps de véritables
friches de loisirs des exemples existent
autour de nous c'est toute la
problématique des lois de mise aux
normes sur les bâtiments l'accessibilité
le littoral qui engendre des fraises
importants pour un usage qui lui reste
saisonnier je suis frappé de comparer
les moyens des colonies privées avec
celles qui dépendent de la gestion
publique alors parlons du coup pour les
enfants dont les parents ne bénéficient
pas d'un comité d'entreprises puissant
et qui doit faire le choix entre un
départ estival familial et l'inscription
d'un enfant dans un centre de vacances
pour les pas une famille les plus
modestes l'intervention coordonnée de la
CAF et des CCAS reste très efficace et
permet le départ du plus grand nombre en
Loire-Atlantique le dispositif vacaf
prend en charge une partie non
négligeable des coûts pour accoucher en
familial à 100 à 475 euros chez 75% de
la facture qui est pris en charge pour
un quotient familial entre 476 et 625
euros c'est 65%
les municipalités les comités
d'entreprise ne répercutent pas
entièrement le coût réel des prestations
sur les usagers les modules des
participations en fonction de leur
quotient familiaux mais en revanche les
associations n'ont pas les moyens de
procéder de la même façon dans le cadre
de l'organisation de leur colonie de
vacances
la deuxième proposition et la
réintroduction des finalités éducatives
au cœur des projets portés par les
colonies de vacances il est avéré que
les colonies de vacances relèvent d'une
forme d'éducation active en parallèle de
la reconquête de la mixité sociale
réhabiliter l'affinité finalité
pédagogique de ces séjours sera
complémentaire de l'offre commerciale
qui se développe pour un autre public il
semble pertinent d'engager une réflexion
sur la complémentarité éventuelle entre
les séjours collectifs des mineurs en
période estivale et l'année scolaire
désormais soumise aux activités
pédagogiques périscolaires lesquels
pourraient être groupés lors de milican
concrètement il faut soutenir les
colonies de vacances qui mettent au cœur
de leurs projets des activités
éducatives reconnues par l'État et les
cruciales de mettre en avant des
activités qui répondent à des objectifs
supérieurs dans le développement de
l'enfant comme l'apprentissage de vivre
ensemble les jumelages qui ont été déjà
cités ou encore l'initiation au
développement durable
des activités de proximité de plein air
ayant une valeur ajoutée éducative
permettrait de rendre les séjours
collectifs accessibles au plus grand
nombre
la troisième proposition de prioritaire
selon nous concerne le statut de
l'animateur faut-il instaurer à
volontariat de l'animation tels que le
préconise la proposition de vin du
rapport Ménard l'arrêt de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne d'octobre
2010 a mis à mal le contrat d'engagement
éducatif qui donnait un statut
dérogatoire au moniteur et directeur de
colonie de vacances et de centre de
loisirs je suis attaché au fait que les
colliers de vacances restant cadrés par
des jeunes qui souhaitent s'engager il
faudra au moins rester dans un cadre de
mission d'intérêt général à partir du
BAFA ou du BAFD les emplois saisonniers
avec des rémunérations et des
cotisations légales les titres
nécessaires ou équivalence à
l'encadrement des accueils sont nombreux
si on s'arrête aux deux principaux le
BAFA et le BFD on constate que pour ces
deux diplômes il y a là à prélever c'est
de l'ordre moyen de 1060 euros pour les
deux stages nécessaires pour l'obtention
de ces diplômes
or pour un temps d'utilisation qui est
relativement court puisque un BAFA
maximum d'utilisation c'est 8 ans et il
est très rare d'ailleurs qu'un animateur
soit l'animateur pendant 8 années en
réalité et quant à BFD c'est 4 années
donc c'est vraiment un investissement
sur un temps très très court et ce titre
est périssable et doit être actualisé
régulièrement ce n'est pas un diplôme de
professionnel il ne concerne que les
animateurs et les directeurs
occasionnels les conditions actuelles
d'emploi sont problématiques la
législation est trop lourde et complexe
et d'aspiration sécuritaire exagérée de
même le repos compensateur entraîne une
augmentation de 20% de la masse
salariale revenons à l'esprit des
colonies qui reposent sur le temps
partagé entre les animateurs et les
enfants une négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux doit être une
solution avant de légiférer sur le
statut d'animateur bénévole le rapport
propose un volontariat de l'animation
réservé au milieu associatif où le
moniteur s'acquitte de manière
désintéressée d'une mission d'intérêt
général et reçoit en compensation
indemnité et une formation bien entendu
cette activité doit être occasionnelle
il faut pouvoir valoriser et compétences
acquises dans le cadre de ce volontariat
dans le parcours scolaire et
professionnel pour terminer je regrette
que le projet de loi sur l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui vient d'être
discutée dans notre assemblée n'aborde
pas le sujet des colonie de vacances
elles peuvent devenir un secteur phare
de l'économie sociale et solidaire si
elle se regroupe se structure se fédère
et quelle sorte pour notre action du
champ d'application des marchés publics
ou à défaut en étendant aux appels
d'offres les critères de mixité sociale
et de finalité éducative de séjour mes
chers collègues la situation des
colliers de vacances est préoccupante la
prépondérance d'opérateur a but lucratif
participe à l'inflation des prix et à
une course à la surenchère au niveau des
offres au détriment du sens premier des
colonies de vacances qui reposent sur le
vivre ensemble d'enfants de tous
horizons sociaux culturels
merci
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
j'ai le très grand plaisir au nom du
Sénat tout entier de saluer la présence
dans notre tribune officielle d'une
délégation du Sénat du Tadjikistan
conduite par Monsieur oubalid président
du Sénat du Tadjikistan et aussi maire
de Douchanbé nous sommes
particulièrement sensibles à l'intérêt
et à la sympathie que vous portez à
notre institution cette délégation est
accompagnée par notre collègue monsieur
Yves Pozzo di Borgo président du groupe
d'amitié France Tadjikistan au nom du
Sénat de la République je leur souhaite
la bienvenue et je forme les vœux que
pour leur séjour en France contribue à
renforcer les liens d'amitié entre nos
deux pays
la parole est à Monsieur Michel
lescarnec pour le groupe CRC
si le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues les colonies de vacances
font partie de la culture populaire au
double sens du terme populaire parce
qu'elles ont accueillies et continuent
de le faire des millions d'enfants et de
jeunes même si les statistiques montrent
une régression de la fréquentation
populaire parce qu'elles offrent un
point de vue socio-culturel du point de
vue sur culturel la possibilité de
vacances aux enfants des familles de
catégories socialement moyennes et
modestes elle cultive ainsi une vraie
mixité sociale nombreux sont ceux qui
ont des souvenirs de colonie de vacances
des histoires à raconter des photos à
montrer ou des objets de souvenirs
qui incarnent tel sac de sac à dos des
expériences ces espaces cet espace-temps
est avant tout un lieu émotionnel de
rencontre de disputes et d'amitié et
même parfois d'amour
vous êtes d'accord bah alors voilà moi
j'ai fait aussi pas mal de colos elle
permet une appréhension du monde concret
au rythme des transports collectifs à la
sueur de la marche à pied ou aux longues
soirées enchantées par l'éveillés les
colos sont ainsi passés d'une création
par le secteur associatif à une
appropriation par le secteur marchand de
la quasi gratuité grâce à l'encadrement
par des bénévoles au séjour payant suite
à une professionnalisation des
personnels ces derniers ont d'abord été
très mal rémunérés je vais vous le dire
vous avez peut-être l'oublier par
exemple en 1969 je percevais 10 francs
de la journée
soit un tiers du SMIC à le SMIC était
entre 900 et 1000 francs
sur les
séjours du rêve 23 jours donc c'était
presque du bénévolat vous gagnez à peine
300 francs et aux dépenser déjà la
moitié pendant le séjour pour la journée
de repos vous souvenez bien
sur les 12200 organisateurs de ces jours
avec hébergement recensés en 2011
8368% sur des associations et seulement
3500 soit 29% des collectivités
territoriales ça vous rappelle votre
Genèse vous l'aviez oublié le rapport
parlementaire sur l'accessibilité des
jeunes au séjour collectives et de
loisirs rendu le 12 juillet 2013 je vous
demande anniversaire c'est un bilan de
colonies aujourd'hui
en préambule il considère que les coloss
de vacances s'inscrivent dorénavant dans
un nouveau contexte où la relation entre
les jeunes et leur temps de loisirs
c'est considérablement transformé au fil
du temps il pourra être aussi un
émiètement de la fréquentation des colos
depuis 20 ans le taux de départ des 5-19
ans si je collectif de vacances depuis
le 5 nuits c'est-à-dire en colis de
vacances qui atteint qui avait atteint
14% vous l'avez déjà dit certains
d'entre vous en 95 d'autres ont dit un
million de nuitées 28 millions à
l'époque n'est plus que le 7 et demi
donc en 2011 et pour des séjours plus
courts cette évolution préoccupante
mérite d'être souligné et doit être mise
en lien avec la hausse des prix de colo
des colonies entre 400 euros et 600
euros maintenant par enfant pour une
semaine par jour c'est entre 63 et 75
tout dépend de la distance entre le
domicile et le lieu de séjour les
vacances d'une manière générale
devraient être un droit pour tous la
crise actuelle est une menace qui pèse
sur les budgets pour preuve 30% de nos
enfants ne seraient jamais parti en
vacances cette situation est grave car
les besoins existent encore plus
aujourd'hui qu'hier du fait de la
pauvreté grandissante du chômage qui
s'étend chômage de masse de la précarité
qui galope mais les coups ont fortement
augmenté de l'ordre de génitales de 103
à 75 euros la journée doit repli
important des familles sur les centres
aérés et si elle est ça je vous les a
LSH
qu'ils organisent les communes et les
caisses d'allocations familiales ont
beaucoup investi ces dernières années
c'est vrai
de même que pour l'accueil de la petite
enfance
le coût en est très intérieur parce
qu'en plus les communes lorsqu'elles
sont organisatrices mettent en place un
calcul tarif basé sur le quotient
familial avec quatre cinq tarifs qui
permet d'ailleurs d'assurer la mixité
sociale dans ses centres aéré
néanmoins je dirais tout à l'heure que
ça n'a pas la même porté que les
colliers de vacances ou les classes de
découverte
quant au comité d'entreprise les ce ils
ont peu à peu préféré se tourner vers
les opérateurs à but lucratifs pour les
vacances des enfants et de leur salarié
délaissant la majeure partie des colis
traditionnels organisées par des
associations ou des collectivités
territoriales heureusement certains
c'est eux continuent d'y croire et de
s'y investir comme le ce la SNCF avec
14000 enfants concernés tout comme les
organismes tels que les associations de
Pupilles de l'enseignement public les
peps chez nous dans le Morbihan les peps
56 Gr 6 centres de vacances deux bases
de voile soit 1000 lits au total en un
an ils accueillent 17000 enfants ou ado
dont 13500 en colo ou classe de
découverte en gros c'est un tiers en
colo deux tiers en classe de découverte
malgré cet engagement exceptionnel il
aurait promis la suppression au minimum
madame la ministre d'un poste de
direction
tous ces aléas conjugués avec
l'augmentation des coûts en paie les
jeunes qui en ont le plus besoin
d'accéder à ces séjours la réalisation
d'un objectif de mixité sociale est
ainsi compromise c'est extrêmement
préjudiciable pour leur avenir car
malgré l'intérêt des centres aérés
ceux-ci sont loin de répondre aux
meubles objectifs mais par contre ils
sont très complémentaires la peur
éducatif la construction de l'autonomie
l'apprentissage de la vie en groupe ou
en collectivité l'éducation à la
citoyenneté tout ceci en dehors du
cercle familial c'est j'allais dire
c'est extra bon
c'est un apport comparable à celui du
classe de découverte pendant la période
scolaire elle les deux formules
permettent aux enfants de s'épanouir car
elle les place en situation de réussite
je le dis je l'ai vécu à maintes
reprises je n'y croyais pas au départ
mais la classe de découverte permet de
débloquer la plupart la plupart des
enfants qui ont des difficultés c'est là
en travaux manuel ou un sport ou en
chant en activité dite d'éveil que
l'enfant trouve ça son autonomie et
permet d'être mis en valeur il a besoin
d'ennemis en valeur sinon si on veut
qu'il y ait des choux laissons-le en
échec de mon sa feuille blanche et il
est sûr de ne pas réussir
je dis avec mon coeur parce que j'ai
vraiment été à chaque fois très très
surpris ils ont la plupart des enfants
changent et surtout ceux qui étaient qui
avaient instable blocage
évidemment le cours du séjour est moins
élevé pourquoi parce que case de
découvert les enseignants en cadre et
ils ont des parents d'élèves de
l'Amicale ou du conseil d'école qui
accompagne et quelques fois il faut
venir même le maire oui pour le rajeunir
il est arrivé que le maire accompagne
des parents d'élèves en bénévole c'est
excellent je peux vous dire on reste en
lien avec le réel
à l'heure où l'on parle de décrochage
scolaire et d'échecs graves on en parle
beaucoup dans les commissions et à tous
les niveaux et dans la presse dans les
médias ça concerne 15 à 20% des élèves
il serait tout de même dommageable de ne
pas aller soutenir les colos c'est
d'abord à l'état de maintenir ses aides
car cette contribution à la réussite
scolaire est un très grand bénéfice pour
la société et ça personne ne l'avait dit
on n'a pas calculé mais il n'est jamais
pris en compte dans le calcul du coup un
séjour ou pour le budget de la France
les vacances qui peuvent sembler normal
pour certains sont en réalité un
véritable luxe pour une grande partie de
la population
pourtant on doit être anodine elles
peuvent jouer le rôle de déclencheur et
de levier pour aider les familles en
difficulté à reprendre une activité à
reprendre l'espoir à reprendre des
initiatives la volonté de s'en sortir et
de surmonter les obstacles parce que
l'enfant qui s'en va en colo ça peut
entraîner aussi la famille la famille
vers le haut le tout conçu bien sûr à
une vision sociale avec un
accompagnateur et une aide financière
appropriée c'est un formidable outil
d'action et de promotion sociale qu'il
ne faut pas sous-estimer il nous semble
donc particulièrement important
aujourd'hui de réaffirmer une volonté de
réappropriation des colonies par toutes
les classes sociales on les revalorisant
comme lieu de transmission privilégiée
de l'éducation populaire la vision des
pays de vacances que je dessinais pas
celles qui s'impose forcément
aujourd'hui et je le regrette
l'éducation populaire qui s'était
fortement développée dans les années 60
avait pour finalité la formation
critique des citoyens dans une politique
d'éducation
large visant l'émancipation par des
savoirs et des pédagogies d'éveil
accessibles aux plus grand nombre en
face de cette situation la tentation est
grande de renoncer à la
professionnalisation des animateurs à
cause du coup de réduire leurs droits en
diminuant leur salaire ou en augmentant
leur temps de travail voire de recourir
au bénévolat
cela serait un tort la question du coût
des colonies de l'accès des classes
populaires à ces dernières ne se résout
en aucun cas par la création de nouveaux
travailleurs pauvres nous appelons donc
les pouvoirs publics amener des
politiques sociales visant à favoriser
le départ d'un maximum d'enfants et
d'adolescents les colonies de vacances
demeurent un des rares espaces de mixité
et de cohésion sociale il convient de
les préserver et mieux dans d'augmenter
le nombre
l'intercommunalité en marche pourrait
être un levier judicieux pour relancer
le droit aux vacances pour tous dans
l'esprit de la coopération des
territoires encore faut-il impulser
cette idée novatrice mais rien ne pourra
se faire si l'État ne se préoccupe pas
d'urgence de l'avenir des centres de
colonies de vacances nous sommes plus
inquiets aujourd'hui qu'hier avec la
réduction très forte des dotations
communes il y a l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales d'autant
plus que des charges nouvelles vont leur
incomber tels que la mise en place des
nouveaux rythmes scolaires je suis pas
contre mais il faut trouver l'argent une
certaine réduction des coûts peut être
obtenue en limitant l'éloignement des
centres de séjour quelque chose enfin
quelques éléments de recettes
éventuelles en obtenant des tarifs très
privilégiés de la SNCF par ailleurs les
caves devraient fléchir des crédits plus
importants de la branche famille la NCV
pourrait créer un chèque séjour
collectif enfant jeunesse il faudrait
par ailleurs que les salariés des TP
obtiennent des chèques-vacances pourquoi
ne pas instaurer également mais ça ça a
été abordé en disant non pour collègues
dufo une taxe spécifique sur
l'hôtellerie de luxe je ne sais pas si
une question
les vendre au secteur immobilier en tout
cas comme j'ai vu le faire quelques fois
au bord de mer c'est ce qu'il y a de
pire pour l'avenir de notre pays et de
notre jeunesse par contre ça rapporte de
collectivités mais en fait c'est une
grande perte pour l'avenir par ailleurs
un intérêt supplémentaire au
développement de nos colonies de
vacances réside dans l'activité
économique touristique de nos
territoires qu'ils soient de montagne de
littoral ou de nos campagnes en effet en
considérant que celles et ceux qui
fréquentent et apprennent à aimer ces
espaces naturels pendant leur jeunesse
seront les touristes de demain il nous
sent l'important de relancer cette
fréquentation au travers des colis de
vacances c'est apprentissage précoce
permettrait de les
montrez non pas comme des domaines
réservés à quelques initiés mais bien
comme des espaces ouverts et de qualité
pour tous le fait d'autres questions
surgissent notamment je vois que je vais
dépasser un peu mais c'est exceptionnel
c'est la première fois pour mon compte
personnel
je
vais prendre mon élan je vais y aller
monsieur Dufour n'ayant pas consommé
tout son temps vous pouvez le prendre il
me donne c'est bien il y a un pont
quelquefois qui peut comme ça exister de
fait d'autres questions surgissent
notamment la réhabilitation des centres
d'accueil et d'hébergement confrontés à
leur obsolescence et leur vieillissement
la question de la sécurité aussi limite
l'accueil des jeunes publiques notamment
dans les refuges en montagne malgré un
texte de juillet 2003 qui permettent
d'utiliser dans la plupart des cas le
support refuge
l'avenir des colos et l'affaire de tous
pas seulement pour le plaisir et le
bonheur des vacances collectives mais
surtout pour que la société de demain
retrouve force confiance et espoir en
l'avenir l'école républicaine est
concernée au premier chef je pense que
tous les futurs enseignants ça c'est une
idée à creuser je pense que tous les
futurs enseignants devraient avoir
l'obligation d'encadrer au moins une
fois le minimum une colonie de vacances
et participer à une classe de découverte
dans le cadre de la formation initiale
et ça peut aider à faire baisser un peu
le prix c'est un complément de formation
indispensable selon moi on n'a pas
discuté dans le groupe mais c'est bon
une immersion dans le réel
et cela les inciterait à devenir plus
tard des enseignants proches des
familles une implication citoyenne comme
du temps des écoles normales la question
du devenir des colonies donc aussi
l'affaire du ministre de l'éducation
nationale dit de lui bien c'est un temps
qui doit être très riche pour les
enfants mais aussi pour les moniteurs et
les enseignants elles sont à la fois le
bonheur conjugué à l'essorhumain
indispensable à notre jeunesse et leur
famille notre groupe très attaché au
progrès social a toujours
œuvré pour les centres de vacances et le
droit aux vacances pour tous à nous de
faire vivre la mixité sociale qui tire
tous nos jeunes vers le haut vers la
réussite et le rayonnement rien ne
serait pire que l'existence de cologetto
les unes pour les riches les autres pour
les plus pauvres il en va de notre
intérêt à tous merci de votre attention
merci Monsieur le square nec la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Bernard manier pour
le groupe socialiste
c'est le Président Madame ministre mes
chers collègues les jolies colonies de
vacances célébrés par la chanson
populaire ont été à l'origine imaginées
par des associations caritatives qui
avaient une motivation hygiéniste et
morale ainsi elles ont organisées des
séjours collectifs afin de revivre les
enfants en les envoyant à la campagne la
mer ou la montagne et de favoriser leur
développement physique et moral par des
exercices au grand air au soleil ou dans
l'eau puis certains ont eu la loi de
l'intention d'éviter aux enfants l'ennui
de dans leur quartier pendant les
vacances scolaires alors ils ont ouvert
des colonies de vacances d'été sans
vocation curative mais à but éducatif et
si les premières colonies de vacances
sont confessionnelles une concurrence
s'installe progressivement entre
œuvres religieuses et œuvre scolaire
laïque et à l'initiative des caisses des
écoles dans certaines municipalités très
vite le nombre de jeunes vacanciers
augmente passant de en 1905 à 100 000 en
1913 puis 220000 en 1938 la croissance
rapide du nombre des colonies des
colonies ainsi d'ailleurs l'État a
intervenir pour les réglementés ainsi
entre 1949 et 1959 l'État soutient une
politique de départ en colonie d'été du
plus grand nombre possible dans sondages
scolaires le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale consacre à cette politique des
moyens humains et budgétaires importants
il organise la formation des équipes
d'encadrement et finances la
construction de centres de vacances
ces centres de vacances répartis dans
plusieurs régions de France et en
Bretagne en particulier représente une
plus-value réelle pour le tourisme rural
l'organisation de ces jours de vacances
soutient à la fois l'oeuvre l'offre
sociale et l'extension géographique dans
des territoires ruraux de montagne ou de
campagne parfois reculées ou peu
accessible
ainsi l'âge d'or des colonies de
vacances d'été durera jusqu'au milieu
des années 60 la fréquentation des
colonies d'été ne commencera à diminuer
qu'en 1966 mais déjà dès 1958 éducation
nationale c'était des engagés de leur
organisation et le ministère des Sports
on a repris la tutelle administrative ce
retrait se traduit par une diminution de
la participation des instituteurs qui
évoquaient tout à l'heure notre collègue
à l'encadrement des séjours et par une
réduction progressive des mises à
disposition des enseignants rapidement
les associations adaptent avec succès
l'organisation et le contenu de leur
séjour à la demande des familles des
collectivités locales et des comités
d'entreprise sur lesquels reposent
désormais la majeure partie du film du
financement des colonies de vacances je
voudrais moi aussi rappeler les effets
bénéfiques spécifiques des colonies de
vacances tout d'abord elles permettent à
des enfants de partir en vacances bien
sûr de nombreux enfants s'il n'avaient
pas accès à ces formules demeure raide à
leur domicile durant toutes les vacances
scolaires et je veux rappeler ici les
différentes aides à ces départs les
aides des municipalités les aides des
comités d'entreprises des allocations
familiales
bon les enfants les plus défavorisés les
séjours en colonie de vacances donnent
un cadre ils peuvent manger équilibrés
dormir dans de bonnes conditions enfin
la plupart du temps avoir un rythme de
vie régulier et dialoguer avec des
adultes ces séjours privilégie la
liberté de jouer ils apprennent à
l'enfant à se diriger lui-même dans sa
vie il développe ses qualités à agir
plus tard en tant que citoyen actif
d'une démocratie car les jeux collectifs
sont différents des exercices scolaires
le séjour collectif de loisirs renverse
la logique de l'école qui ne laisse aux
récréations qu'une phase tout à fait une
place tout à fait subalterne dans la
journée d'apprentissage au contraire les
colonies de vacances exploite toutes les
potentialités mulatrices des récréations
et du jeu
l'éducation active par le jeu encourage
la solidarité entre les enfants d'un
même âge et la cohésion du groupe est
imposée par la permanence de la vie
collective qui empêche les enfants de se
replier sur eux-mêmes ainsi ils
apprennent tu as surmonter leurs
inhibitions leur déception leur crainte
par la présence permanente des autres
par la répétition des épreuves qu'ils
ont pu redouter auquel ils ont pu
échouer par la simplicité des jeux et
par le renversement des rôles d'un jour
à l'autre l'éducation nationale et les
autres institutions en charge de
l'accueil et de l'éducation des enfants
ont accepté les principes de l'éducation
active à partir des années 70 en
développant les activités d'éveil des
méthodes pratiques d'instruction et des
activités ludiques périscolaires le
modèle de l'éducation active repose sur
quatre principes le jeu collectif la
constitution de petits groupes la vie
collective continue jour et nuit et
l'encadrement par de jeunes moniteurs
l'éducation collective par le jeu et
l'innovation principale de cette méthode
l'hébergement collectif inhérents à la
colonie de vacances est un vecteur
d'émancipation tous les acteurs
collectifs tous les accueils collectifs
de mineurs qu'il s'agisse d'accueil de
loisirs d'accueil de vacances de séjour
de scoutisme ou itinérant en France
comme à l'étranger tous ces accueils
favorisent la socialisation des jeunes
qui participent par leur intégration
dans un groupe de leur âge les colonies
de vacances sont l'occasion d'une
séparation de l'enfant de sa famille
mais aussi de ces éducateurs habituels
et de son milieu de vie quotidien seul
en fratrie ou même entre copains les
enfants qui partent en colo quittent les
leur lieu de résidence et leur terrain
habituel de jeux familiers pour partir à
l'aventure dans des régions inconnues et
retrouver sur place d'autres enfants de
leur âge et des animateurs qui ne
connaissaient pas
le groupe réunit lors d'un séjour de
vacances est occasionnel est composé de
personnes qui pour la plupart ne vont se
fréquenter assidûment que pendant la
durée du séjour sans pouvoir s'éviter
mais en sachant qu'il se perdront de vue
par la suite
chaque participant est invité à partager
des moments de jeu de convivialité et
aussi d'intimité sans que cela prête à
conséquence pour sa vie quotidienne
encore des vacances les jeunes peuvent
faire des expériences se découvrir des
aspects nouveaux et inconnus de leur
propre personnalité
et cette émancipation progresse avec
l'avancée en âge du jeune vacancier
parce qu'on lui laisse davantage
d'initiative dans les activités pour ces
raisons on constate que si les enfants
sont pas parfois inquiets de partir en
colonies de vacances ils sont toujours
tristes dans revenir
on remarque en outre que parfois les
jeunes qui ont fréquenté des colonies de
vacances à l'adolescence sont envie de
suivre une formation pour intégrer une
équipe d'encadrement pour la plupart de
ceux qui fréquentent les colos ces uns
et l'âge du dernier départ et environ 5%
d'entre eux entreprennent dans la foulée
les démarches les démarches pour obtenir
le BAFA et bien souvent ces jeunes prêts
à se dévouer au service des autres sont
tentés par un engagement social et
parfois militant qui motivera les
intéressés tout au long de leur vie
personnelle et professionnelle
aujourd'hui on constate de plus en plus
une professionnalisation de l'animation
c'est même devenu une revendication
syndicale soutenue par une jurisprudence
européenne qui vient modifier l'économie
du secteur des loisirs des jeunes qui
auparavant c'était constitué dans un
mode dans un monde associatif en marge
du salariat et du droit commun du
travail
une partie des animateurs occasionnels
ne considèrent plus l'encadrement d'un
groupe de mineurs comme une activité
militante ou bénévole et celui d'un
séjour collectif comme une forme
d'engagement éducatif et de vacances
indemnisées mais comme un travail de
quelques semaines mal rémunéré que l'on
accepte faute de mieux dans une période
de chômage de masse en espérant qu'il
soit considéré comme une expérience
professionnelle et qu'il compte pour la
retraite il en va de même des brevets
d'aptitudes de fonctions d'animateurs au
directeur d'accueil collectif des
mineurs qui sont considérés comme la
première étape d'un parcours de
qualification professionnelle dans les
métiers de l'action sociale et de
l'enfance la professionnalisation est
cependant difficile à imaginer dans le
secteur des séjours de vacances divisé
en prof commercial et fonction sociale
organisateur associatif et société à
bureaucratif qui n'utilise près de 150
000 animateurs et directeurs
occasionnels que quelques semaines
pendant un an ou deux
car dans les centres de loisirs de
vacances la réglementation exige
désormais la détention d'un diplôme
sportif pour la pratique d'un très grand
nombre croissant d'activités ce qui
établit un double séparation selon le
sexe et selon la qualification des
animateurs brevetés sans diplôme et des
animateurs diplômés à présent on fait
une différence entre le bénévolat et
l'engagement on attend sa pensée que
qualité égale professionnelle et que
bénévole
= amateur on craint que les amateurs
bénévoles plus animateurs bénévoles ne
soient pas à la hauteur en conséquence
est compte tenu du fait que les
exigences de sécurité des hébergements
des déplacements des activités notamment
physiques et sportives sont accrues par
une réglementation qui impose toujours
plus de qualifications à l'encadrement
la présence des animateurs occasionnels
indemnisées plutôt que salariés et mis
en cause elle est d'autant plus qu'en
deux secteurs d'activités connexes celui
du sport
d'une part et celui de l'accueil de la
petite enfance de l'autre sont de plus
en plus réservés à des professionnels
diplômés
on en est venu à distinguer le monde
professionnel du monde occasionnel de
l'animation le premier concerne les
accueils de loisirs dans lesquels existe
la juxtaposition des types de contrats a
duré indéterminée déterminée ou
d'engagement éducatif alors que les
modes de financement de ces accueils qui
accaparent les deux tiers des animateurs
occasionnels brevetés pourraient
supporter un aliment progressif sur les
deux conventions collectives de
l'animation et du sport en revanche le
mode occasionnel par exemple dans le
cadre du volontariat de l'animation
pourrait demeurer le mode dominant
d'encadrement des séjours de vacances
les professionnels n'étant requis que
pour la pratique des activités
dangereuses
comme je l'ai dit précédemment depuis
1995 l'évolution du marché attendu à
faire disparaître les séjours classiques
sans thématiques fréquenter par tous les
milieux sociaux et à séparer les
accueils collectifs de mineurs en deux
secteurs l'un associatif et caritatif
semblable au garderie d'été l'autre
commercial et concurrentiel celui des
camps itinérants de tourisme et
d'aventure pour adolescents des milieux
aisés malheureusement cette évolution
apparaît particulièrement défavorable au
départ en vacances des enfants des
milieux au revenu modestes ou moyens qui
n'ont accès ni aux caritatif ni aux
commerciales ce pour lesquels les
colonies de vacances pourraient être
justement les plus bénéfiques on peut
donc de se demander si à ce niveau il
doit il doit y avoir intervention de
l'État afin de continuer à maintenir
coûte que coûte une offre bon marché de
coaidie de vacances si l'on est
convaincu que ces vacances pour les
enfants sont l'affaire de tous et que
l'on regrette que trop d'enfants ne
quittent plus leur environnement
quotidien une fois de plus
une intervention de l'État apparaîtra
comme la seule solution permettre aux
trois millions d'enfants qui ne partent
pas en vacances d'avoir accès au moins
une fois dans l'année un séjour
collectif représente un besoin estimé à
600 millions d'euros 200 euros pour
chacun pour 3 millions d'enfants pour ce
financement la proposition numéro 1 du
député Michel Ménard dans son rapport
sur l'accessibilité des jeunes au séjour
collectifs et de loisirs et que l'État
crée un Front national d'aide au départ
en vacances collective alimenter par des
recettes nouvelles à cet effet certains
ont proposé le rétablissement d'une taxe
sur l'hôtellerie de luxe qui n'avait été
instauré en décembre 2011 puis supprimer
en décembre de la même année
leur établissement de cette taxe pour le
financement du départ en vacances
collectif des enfants du milieu des
favorisés sur étagère de solidarité
entre famille modestes et familles plus
aisées
mais une taxe de 2 à 6% me rapporterait
que 100 à 200 millions d'euros
dans le rapport que je viens de citer
sont ensuite présentés une vingtaine de
propositions vous les avez évoqué les
uns les autres je n'y reviendrai pas il
serait bien aussi que l'engagement
éducatif est civique d'adolescents et de
jeunes adultes pendant quelques semaines
de vacances restent un acte d'engagement
désintéressé reconnu comme tel il ne
doit pas être dévalorisé en devenant
d'une forme subalterne de salariat
mettant à la disposition des employeurs
une main d'oeuvre conviviable à mon
marché le contrat d'engagement éducatif
devrait répondre à toutes ces
difficultés mais il n'y parvient encore
pas tout à fait
les associations avancent plusieurs
formules de volontariat qui s'articulent
aujourd'hui autour d'une démarche
commune une plateforme conduite par
l'association Jeunesse plein air la zipa
cette démarche revendique le principe
d'un volontariat limité par une durée
fractionnable réservée au milieu
associatif sans but lucratif et agréé
pour l'exercice de mission d'intérêt
collectif général à caractère social et
éducatif bien que cette restriction
puisse introduire une distorsion de
concurrence avec les offres d'accueil de
mineurs proposées par le secteur
commercial la Ligue des enseignement
quant à elle souhaite que le volontariat
ne soit pas utilisé pour l'encadrement
des centres de loisirs pendant les
vacances scolaires les principaux
syndicats représentant les
professionnels de l'animation et du
sport souhaite de leur côté séparer
nettement le statut des salariés de
l'animation de celui des volontaires qui
n'exercerait que pendant les vacances
ainsi on peut aujourd'hui regretter que
la désinfection vis-à-vis des colonies
de vacances qui affaiblit la
connaissance de notre pays par les
jeunes générations l'éducation citoyenne
l'émancipation des vacanciers et des
jeunes qui les encadrent la découverte
et l'aventure collective qui sont les
vertus propres au séjour collectifs en
souffre mais cela est lié à l'évolution
de la société aux diverses craintes
exprimées par les parents au coût trop
élevés des séjours des séjours
collectifs à la hausse du prix des
transports à la baisse des aides
sociales qui projette en charge une
partie de ces prix désormais les enfants
les jeunes partent moins loin moins
longtemps moins souvent quand ils
partent c'est entre en petits groupes
attirés par des activités à la mode
l'affaire du temps de repos des
animateurs sous contrat d'engagement
éducatifs n'a pas arrangé les choses
c'était la norme de trop qui a provoqué
une révolte dans le monde d'écolos et a
ouvert une réflexion collective sur leur
avenir certains disent même que les
colos appartiennent au ringarde
associations de l'éducation populaire
imaginez-vous pour les anciens comme là
on pourrait comme on en parle et les
financeurs sociaux privilégiés à présent
les accueils des loisirs de proximité
mais doivent-ils continuer à le faire en
abandonnant des séjours collectifs de
vacances aux lois du marché à la
segmentation en cours des clientèle à
titre personnel il me paraît préférable
de favoriser pour les séjours de
vacances pour mineur une mixité sociale
territoriale voire éducative et d'éviter
qu'il devienne un produit commercial
comme un autre car les greniers de
vacances associatives ont un rôle clé à
jouer tant pour la cohésion sociale du
pays l'économie du tourisme social
l'éducation à la citoyenneté
l'émancipation des jeunes et la garantie
donne droit aux vacances pour tous je
vous remercie en m'excusant d'avoir été
trop long
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Claude du mézet pour le groupe
socialiste
et
pour ceux qui me concernent j'ai connu
des vacances pendant très longtemps je
l'ai connu à l'époque où j'étais tout
jeune enfant où on allait inconnu
vacances tout simplement pour
pour changer d'air
et quelquefois pour pour manger pour
bien manger
ensuite
les communes vacances sont développées
mais très vite on s'est aperçu que il y
avait des questions de salubrité et de
sécurité qui se posait tout à fait
normalement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle
petit à petit levacances le coût a
augmenté et le coût du séjour a augmenté
et peut-être c'est une des explications
de du rejet peut-être et de la perte de
vitesse et des colonies de vacances
puis il y a eu aussi les structures
familiales la structure familiale a
complètement changé les familles
recomposées faisaient que on part avec
le moment on part avec le papa ou bien
on parle les grands-parents et les
communes ont mis en place des centres de
loisirs pour hébergement les centres
aérés ce qui fait que petit à petit
la fréquentation des colliers vacances à
grandement baissé mais il y a surtout le
coût pour les familles modestes il faut
le lire c'est le coût qui est qui a sans
doute été un des facteurs les plus
redoutables pour les communes vacances
et pourtant
et pourtant le besoin
des
colonies
patins parce que pour les enfants c'est
l'apprentissage de l'autonomie de la
responsabilité en même temps que la vie
en communauté hors du cas de familial
qu'on ne trouve pas bien sûr dans les
centres de loisirs sans hébergement mais
je voudrais revenir à des considérations
plus
d'actualité en ce qui concerne les
vacances en 2003
je m'étais je mettais inquiété de
l'héritage parce qu'il y a un héritage
économie vacances et particulièrement
l'héritage immobilier et dès 2003
j'interrogeais déjà le gouvernement de
l'époque sur le problème posé par la
désaffection du parc immobilier
anciennement
occupé par les colliers de vacances
ce problème si je l'ai posé s'il est
particulièrement prégnant en zone rurale
parce que c'est là que était installé
l'économie de vacances alors à l'époque
on m'avait répondu mais complètement à
côté du sujet sur des mesures
incitatives en faveur de l'habitat dans
les territoires ruraux qui n'avaient
absolument rien à voir parce que quand
vous avez un bâtiment un grand bâtiment
qui est bien souvent dans un état très
presque en ruine pour arriver à
construire ou aller aménager et bien
pour les communes rurales c'est
ça n'est pas possible donc on avait
oublié que les accueils de séjour de
vacances pour mineur sont une plus-value
bien sûr pour le tourisme des
départements les taureaux bien
évidemment mais également de montagne y
compris dans les territoires difficiles
d'accès ainsi les départements des Alpes
du Sud
sont-ils encore aujourd'hui dans le
peloton de tête du nombre de journées de
Conques néanmoins si la mer la fermeture
à la mer la fermetures de centre
vacances pour mineur abouti plus
facilement à une reconversion en
résidence secondaire
ou de tourisme classique par l'accueil
des familles il n'avait pas de même en
montagne ou la fermeture signifie bien
souvent l'abandon du site et ce alors
même que l'activité des centres de
vacances pour mineur sont un soutien non
négligeable de l'économie locale voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire dans cette
dans ce débat et je m'en tiendrai tout
simplement à dire que pour moi
ce qui est préoccupant bien sûr c'est
les vacances c'est bien sûr l'héritage
qui demeure mais c'est surtout
l'accueil l'avenir de l'accueil des
jeunes de ces 3 millions de jeunes qui
ne partent pas en vacances c'est cela
qui est important et c'est vers eux
qu'il faut mettre l'accent pour qu'il
puisse
avoir des vacances descentes surtout les
pluies dévavorisées découvrir un monde
nouveau inconnu pour eux et puis
peut-être tout simplement utiliser aussi
si elle n'est pas négligeable pourquoi
ne pas le dire la possibilité de jouer
de d'être pris en charge et même d'avoir
une alimentation équilibrée je n'ai pas
utilisé mon temps de parole et vous
considérerez que j'ai cédé une partie de
mon temps de parole au groupe CRC compte
tenu des dépassements qu'il avait eu je
n'en tirerai aucun ne remerciement je
vous remercie
nous quittons l'hémicycle du Sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance nous y
reviendrons plus largement dans notre
édition de 19h mais tout de suite ses
preuves par 3 l'émission politique de la
rédaction de Public Sénat qui reçoit ce
soir Michel Barnier commissaire européen
bonne soirée à tout à l'heure